[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> President Clinton, I'm campaigning against
female genital
mutilation.
>> Good for you.
>> Thank you.
>> I won the Davos Debates to get into --
>> You did?
>> I did.
>> Where are you from?
>> I'm from London. I was out in Ethiopia
last year so --
>> You know, when I was President and Hillary
went on a terror against
this -- it's very interesting, when I went
to Africa in '98 I went
around to meet all these people that she had
helped to mobilize, and
one of the most interesting things was going
to the villages and
countries where she had worked to meet with
the women and the few men
who had supported the women and campaigning
against female genital
mutilation.
It's a great cause.
I'll follow up.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Bless you.
>> My heart is going.
That was fantastic.
He's promised to follow up.
He said it's a fantastic cause.
If I can get into the Clinton initiative,
that would be wonderful.
And I think had will follow up, so that's
great.